shakiro blackburn dark souls si todos
somos muy difíciles pero se acuerda
cuando esto fue pasarnos que nos acaban
canas bien ya garden es uno de los
mejores y más difíciles sacas de los
últimos tiempos y afortunadamente una
que tiene muchos secretos sin gloria o
culpa es una pena que actualmente esté
un poco olvidada pero sin duda alguna es
una saga que siempre recordaremos con
cariño cortando cabezas y acabando con
decenas de enemigos a la vez
así que para recordar momentos
dedicación diversión y rabia y sobre
todo para recordar estos grandiosos
títulos hoy veremos todo lo que no
sabías de lo que para mí es el mejor
título de toda la trilogía acompáñame a
curiosidades secretos y detalles del
ninja gaiden 2
su bar
bien llegar en dos fue el juego que
introdujo el gorro y los
desmembramientos a la saga ya que a
pesar de que el ninja gaiden y ninja
gaiden black puedes cortar cabezas en su
segunda parte decir bien un poco más
lejos dándote la oportunidad de cortar
prácticamente cualquier parte conmigo
dejándolo como un tronco en el capítulo
4 llegarás a una zona donde habrá un
pequeño muro de madera que podrá romper
si lo haces encontrarles este distraer
de referencia a xbox incluso interactúas
con él te curará y producirá un sonido
muy característico de las consolas
riu hace una aparición en los juegos de
oral hay como dos armas que puedes
elegir tiene un personaje recurrente de
esta saga hablando de dead or alive
sabes que tiene una película live action
y que rivas eso parece una en ella
aunque claro la película es muy [ __ ] y
el río que aparece en ella también pero
que no lo sabías crack pero [ __ ]
la trilogía moderna de ninja gaiden es
una precuela de la trilogía original
haciendo que todo lo que hemos tenido
llegar en 1 2 y 3 sucederá antes de que
río heredará la espada del dragón de su
padre en el ninja gaiden original en el
ninja quieren original si ese que arribó
tiene entre 21 y 25 años y de aunque los
juegos modernos son precuelas ríos mucho
más joven
así que si el estabas tocando demonios y
enemigos desde bastante joven al iniciar
tercer capítulo podemos ver un edificio
con las palabras de atech que hace
referencia a una compañía muy importante
en el universo de dead or alive los
juegos de lucha donde río aparece en
ella que en todos nos menciona que el
nombre del padre de ryu hayabusa pero
curiosamente en el juego original para
danés el nombre del padre de riu es que
en hayabusa existe un cómic de ninja
gaiden que funcionamos de precuela de
ninja gaiden 2 contándonos los eventos
antes del comienzo del juego
hablando del cómic en este cómic se nos
narra la guerra que tuvo el clan
hayabusa contra los vampiros
tierra la cual río y su padre luchan
juntos para acabar con el líder de los
vampiros mostrándonos lo poderoso que es
el padre del río y los temibles que
llegan a ser de estar juntos haciendo
fin a una larga guerra entre ninjas y
vampiros como sabemos casi el inicio del
juego vemos al padre de riego peleando
contra el game y el líder del clan de la
araña negra y a pesar de que río
interviene en la pelea al final los
dejamos solos luchando pero no sabemos
lo que pasó en ese enfrentamiento bueno
pues resulta que el padre de ríos
sobrevivió la pelea pero quedó ciego
debido a las heridas que quien sí le
causó existen trucos o bueno más bien
inglés donde puedes engañar código del
juego haciendo que el río no pueda
recibir nada de daño haciéndolo
invencible pero que tanto en la
diversión al juego un gran detalle del
juego es que si al pelar manchas tu
espada de la sangre de tus enemigos y
después de acabarlos a todos te quedas
que tu momento yo tendrá una animación
donde limpiará la sangre de su espada
antes de guardarla de nuevo de hecho
esta animación no sólo con la espada ya
que tiene animación única para cada arma
durante el juego por haz encontrar
esparcidos por los mapas en lugares
escondidos una serie de calaveras de
cristal que servirán a manera de
coleccionables del juego
si te las arreglas para conseguir las 30
calaveras de cristal en el capítulo 3 en
cierta parte podrá reclamar la calavera
de cristal' gigante por mucho tiempo se
ha debatido para qué sirve esta calavera
gigante y aunque aún no hay nada
confirmado se dice que la calavera hace
que los enemigos tienen más esencia más
puntos pero también hace que te salgan
más enemigos y que sean más fuertes el
clan hayabusa plan al que río pertenece
son rivales a muerte con el clan de la
araña negra y algo curioso es que en el
de ninja gaiden se nos explica que el
clan hayabusa se fundó con la ayuda de
dragones sagrados su linaje y alma y el
clan de la raya negra se fundó con lo
contrario con el linaje sangre y poder
de los demonios siendo son la razón de
su maldad y la extraña apariencia de
algunos de sus miembros ninja gaiden 2
fue lanzado originalmente como un juego
exclusivo para xbox pero un año después
debió la demanda de los fans se lanzó el
juego para playstation 3 pero bajo el
nombre de ninja gaiden sigma 2 lo que
sería una versión algo mejorada en ninja
gaiden 2 pero la cual vendría con
censura en la versión original del juego
la de xbox la segunda arma que podrías
obtener es el báculo lunar que lo
tomarás de un altar después de derrotar
un par de ninjas para la versión sigma
del juego añadir una mujer extra para
reclamar el báculo en una vez deberías
luchar contra una estatua de buda y
romperle toda su santísima madre
esta versión para playstation 3 de ninja
gaiden 2 no sólo vendría con censura ya
que dañaron mucho contenido como armas
jefes e incluso zonas totalmente nuevas
que jugarían no sólo como ryu sino
también como ayane y móvil y ambas
aliadas de río
se acuerdan de la bruja enorme que
enfrentamos en línea que está en 3
contra la frente es la verdad no sabía
quién era ella o de dónde había salido y
claro pues resulta que esa no fue su
primera aparición o baba como se le
conoce aparecen ninja gaiden sigma 2
como un jefe extra esta bruja es un
miembro del clan de la raya negra que
podría ser líder del clan después de la
muerte de quien sí fue por eso que
muchos de nosotros yo incluido no
sabíamos quién era ella cuando jugamos
de integrante en 3 porque yo no jugué la
versión sigma de ninja gaiden 2 o la
versión original así que nunca supe
quién era ella hasta ninja ver en 3
hablando de esta bruja recuerdan a
muramasa verdad él visitó que nos vendía
cosas así que resulta ser un cabrón con
la espada bien ese puede aparecer en el
pasado en una manga tuvo algún tipo de
relación con esta bruja no sé qué tipo
de relación tuvieron pero se los dejo a
su imaginación
wapa en halo 3 podremos desbloquear una
armadura muy especial la armadura
hayabusa en homenaje a la saga ninja
gaiden otra cosa que podremos
desbloquear halo 3 es la katana de
arriba si conseguimos 50 logros podemos
jugar usando esta espada
la mujer que nos acompaña durante todo
el juego la conocemos como sonia pero
ese no es su verdadero nombre su
verdadero nombre es ir en él
haciendo referencia a un personaje de
los juegos originales con el mismo
nombre gamón es un investigador que
apareciendo en llegue temblaba como
hierba que tenemos que enfrentar y que
muere al final del juego tienen llegar
en dos podemos encontrar una nota donde
se nos revela que gamón era hermano
menor de kenzie
el enemigo final de ninja gaiden todos
lo conocemos durante todo el juego por
el sobrenombre del archi demonio y más
allá de saber qué son los demonios más
poderosos no sabemos mucho más de él
bueno el verdadero nombre del archivo
nio es pasta que según el logro de la
saga es una de las entidades más
poderosas jamás creadas nace a partir
del odio y la maldad reinó la tierra por
mucho tiempo hasta que fue sellado en la
estatua demoníaca por ancestros de
arriba
la espalda no es un arma cualquiera por
la historia nos cuenta que esta
legendaria arm asiste desde hace muchos
muchos años cuando los dragones divinos
de edad es el universo ninja gaiden
fueron traicionados por uno de ellos con
gran parte de su energía agotada usar lo
último de poder que les quedaba para
poner toda su esencia su energía y sus
almas en uno de sus colmillos otorgando
este colmillo a un humano siendo única y
exclusivamente las personas con sangre
del linaje del dragón los que pueden
plantar la espada tanto a su origen alas
para el dragón y al linaje del dragón
pero es para el dragón es un arma
poderosa sí pero se convierte en las
armas más poderosas de la saga
únicamente con el ojo del dragón una
joya que al igual que la espada contiene
parte de las almas de los dragones
divinos la espada por sí sola es fuerte
pero solo puede alcanzar su máximo
potencial cuando estos dos objetos se
juntan formando así la verdadera espada
del dragón esta joya fue talla
directamente de los ojos de uno de los
dragones y su vínculo con la espada es
tan fuerte que puede encontrarla donde
sea cuando -según el ojo el dragón a la
espada se dice que las pátinas pues lo
suficientemente grande como para
desequilibrar el balance en el mundo
haciendo un poder muy rara vez usado por
los peligros que representan
al igual que el hayabusa y el linaje el
dragón tina en la espada del dragón
el clan de la araña negra tiene la
espada del archi demonio esta espada
también se escribe en antiguos mitos del
ninja gaiden se dice que fue creada a
partir de los restos de metal de un
meteorito que fue maldecido por la archi
demonio vas la estas pasos la pueden
portar los miembros más fuertes del clan
de la araña negra siendo el arma
favorita de cannes y cuando la magia
oscura del archivo nio que está sellada
dentro de la espada reacción al poder de
su usuario la hoja desprende energía en
forma de rayos eléctricos rojos la hoja
tiene una descripción en un lenguaje
divino que reza alabado sea el orden
traído por el filo del caos
y bueno ahí lo tienen 30 datos curiosos
secretos y detalles que puede encontrar
sobre el ninja gaiden 2 la raza el juego
tiene bastantes curiosidades pero no
fueron nada fáciles de encontrar
así que prefería que les me gusta si no
sabes al menos una de estas cosas
lohan hacer de esta serie una serie de
curiosidades sobre distintos juegos y
otros temas así que si les gusta no dude
en suscribirse para más si conoce más
secretos de este juego que yo no
comparte los en los comentarios
además digan cuál fue su juego favorito
la trilogía moderna de ninja gaiden
hasta la próxima
[Música]
y
i
[Música]
ah